Hallo, schönen guten Abend. Ich bin Frau Sahin und ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzärztin tätig und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Falls Sie Fragen haben, können Sie mich jederzeit unterbrechen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja. Und zunächst benötige ich Ihre persönliche Daten. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Petra Sommerfeld.
Petra Sommerfeld. Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Sommerfeld?
Ich bin 63 Jahre alt.
Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich bin 1,68 Meter groß und wiege 80 Kilo.
Wie ist Ihr Name von Ihrer Hausarztin bzw. der Ärzte?
Frau Dr. Müller.
Frau Sommerfeld. Was führt Sie heute zu uns?
Ich habe seit ungefähr 4 Wochen Luftnot.
Besonders bei der Belastung, die ich bei Treppen steigen, bekam ich schnell Luftnot.
Auch Hustenreiz.
In den letzten zwei Tagen habe ich auch Luftnot, schon wenn ich in der Wohnung gehe.
Ich muss mich dann oft hinsetzen und das ist nicht gut.
Also vor vier Wochen hatten Sie belastungabhängige Luftnote?
Ja, das hat angefangen. Ich muss Treppen steigen, ich wohne im zweiten Stockwerk.
Dann habe ich das nicht geschafft. Dann musste ich immer am ersten Stockwerk eine Pause machen.
Seit zwei Tagen leiden Sie auch im Ruhe unter Luftnot?
Ja.
Die Atemnot hat sich im Laufe der Zeit verschlechtert?
Sie haben auch gesagt, dass Sie trockene Husten haben?
Ja, der ist manchmal etwas schleimig. Manchmal kommt auch etwas Schleim raus beim Husten.
Das kenne ich sonst gar nicht. Der ist weißlicher Schleim, der manchmal rauskommt.
Haben Sie schon Blut gesehen im Auswurf?
Nein, das habe ich nicht gesehen.
Haben Sie auch Halsschmerzen?
Nein, Halsschmerzen habe ich nicht.
Frau Sommerfeld, haben Sie auch in den letzten vier Wochen Herzrasen, Herzklopfen, solche Beschwerden?
Ja, mein Herz schlägt etwas schneller.
Etwas schneller? Fühlen Sie das oder haben Sie Ihre Puls gemessen?
Ich habe den Puls gefühlt und ich messe auch zwischendurch meinen Blutdruck, weil ich auch hohen Blutdruck habe.
Da habe ich gemerkt, dass der Puls normalerweise zwischen 80 und 90 ist.
Jetzt ist er manchmal in Ruhe auch bei 100.
Seit wie vielen Jahren leiten Sie Bluthochdruck?
So acht Jahre.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Ich nehme drei verschiedene Mittel.
Einmal heißt das Candesatan.
Wie ist die Dosierung?
Hinter steht acht und dann nehme ich morgens eine und abends eine.
Dann nehme ich noch ein Mittel, das heißt Bisopolol.
Da steht fünf hinter.
Da nehme ich morgens eine und abends eine halbe.
Und dann nehme ich noch ein Mittel, da muss ich dann oft auf Toilette gehen, Wasser lassen.
Das heißt Furusemit.
Dahinter steht 40.
Wie viel nehmen Sie diese?
Am Morgen.
Okay, also Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie manchmal Herzrasen haben.
Haben Sie in den letzten vier Wochen Ihre Fieber gemessen?
Nein, habe ich nicht gemessen, aber ich habe nicht den Eindruck, dass ich Fieber habe.
Ich glaube nicht, aber ich habe nicht gemessen.
Aber Sie haben sich auch nicht fieberig gefühlt?
Nein.
Wenn Sie Fieber hätten, würden Sie das fühlen?
Ja, dann hätte ich das schon gelesen.
Dann hätten Sie das fühlen.
Und Sie haben auch nicht unter Nachschweiß oder Schüttelfrost auch nicht gelitten?
Nein.
Wie ist das mit Ihrem Appetit, Frau Sommerfeld?
Ja, mein Appetit, da hat sich nicht groß verändert.
Ich muss ja immer ein bisschen aufpassen, weil ich ja auch Zucker habe.
Und da soll ich immer ein bisschen vorsichtig sein mit dem Essen.
Das gelingt mir mehr oder weniger gut.
Nicht immer.
Ja, ich verstehe. Sie leiden auch an Zuckerkrankheit.
Seit zwei Jahren nehme ich da auch eine Tablette ein.
Das Mittel heißt Metformin.
Ja, wie viel Milligramm? Ist die Dosierung ja bekannt?
Dahinter steht 850.
850, da nehme ich eine morgens und eine halbe zur Nacht.
Eine halbe am Nacht?
Ja, zur Nacht.
Okay, habe ich verstanden.
Ist Ihnen noch andere chronische Erkrankungen bekannt?
Nein.
Also Sie leiden nur an Bluthochdruck und Zuckerkrankheit?
Ja.
Haben Sie in den letzten vier Wochen ungewollt ab- oder zugenommen?
Ja, in den letzten vier Wochen ist mir aufgefallen.
Da habe ich fast fünf Kilogramm zugenommen.
Haben Sie Schluckbeschwerden, Frau Sommerfeld?
Nein.
Leiden Sie unter Brustschmerzen?
Nein, auch nicht.
Sie hatten nur Husten und Atemnot?
Okay.
Gibt es irgendjemand in Ihrem Umfeld, der mit dem gleichen Beschwerden unter den Husten ist?
Nein, ich kenne keinen.
Das ist mir nicht bekannt.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Ja, ich wurde als Kind am Nabelbruch und an den Mandeln operiert.
Da war ich so, glaube ich, zehn Jahre alt, neun Jahre alt.
Vor zwölf Jahren wurde mir die Gallenblase entfernt.
Ich hatte Steine und eine Bauchspeicheldrüsenentzündung.
Das hängt mit den Gallensteinen zusammen.
Deswegen wurde die Gallenblase entfernt.
Sie hatten eine Nabelbruchoperation und eine Mandelentzündung.
Als Sie zwölf Jahre alt waren.
Ja, in der Kindheit.
Okay.
Außer diesen vier Medikamenten, die Sie schon genannt haben,
gibt es noch andere Medikamente, die Sie regelmäßig oder beigetragen einnehmen?
Nein.
Ist bei Ihnen Allergin bekannt, Frau Sommerfeld?
Nein, ich habe keine Allergin.
Raufen Sie, Frau Sommerfeld?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Super. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, aber ganz wenig.
Wenn mal eine Geburtstagsfeier ist oder so etwas,
dann trinke ich vielleicht mal ein Glas Wein, aber das ist selten.
Ja, okay.
Ich habe noch eine Frage, Frau Sommerfeld, aber bitte nehmen Sie es nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein.
Toll. Treiben Sie Sport?
Regelmäßig?
Nein.
Treiben Sie auch keinen Sport?
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, da achtet meine Hausärztin immer drauf.
Da gehe ich auch einmal im Jahr, im Herbst immer zur Grippeimpfung und hin.
Ich hatte allerdings jetzt vor sechs Wochen Corona.
Oder sieben Wochen hatte ich Corona.
Da hatte ich dann auch einige Tage Fieber und so.
Da ging es mir nicht gut.
Aber ich habe mich eigentlich davon dann wieder ganz gut jetzt erholt.
Bis auf jetzt die Luftnot.
Vor wie vielen Wochen hatten Sie vor sieben Wochen?
Ja.
Ist bei Ihnen Corona-diagnosiert?
Wie schlafen Sie? Schlafen Sie gut, Frau Sommerfeld?
Seitdem ich jetzt diese Luftnot habe und auch den Husten, schlafe ich nicht so gut.
Weil ich muss jetzt dann auch nachts häufig auf Toilette und Wasser lassen.
Normalerweise muss ich immer einmal.
Aber jetzt muss ich zwischen drei und fünf Mal auf Toilette und Wasser lassen.
Okay. Danke, Stamper.
Sind Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland gewesen?
Also ich war im Oktober war ich eine Woche in Italien, in Rom.
Aber sonst war ich nicht im Ausland.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Vor Monaten.
Okay.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie bekannte chronische Erkrankungen?
Also mein Vater, der ist im Alter von 76 Jahren verstorben an Herzschwäche.
Sie ist damals, der hat ein schwaches Herz und daran ist er gestorben.
Es tut mir leid zu hören.
Die Mutter, die lebt, die ist 86 Jahre alt.
87 Jahre ist die Mutter, die hat Asthma und die hat eine schwere Kniearthrose.
Auf beiden Knien.
Dann habe ich noch einen Bruder, der ist 60 Jahre alt, der hat auch hohen Blutdruck und erhöhtes Cholesterin.
Okay. Sind Sie verheiratet, Frau Sommerfeld?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet und lebe mit meinem Mann zusammen.
Haben Sie auch Kinder?
Ja, wir haben zwei Kinder, die sind 30 Jahre alt und 32 Jahre, die sind gesund.
Gesund. Okay, super toll.
Also Frau Sommerfeld, das waren die Fragen, die ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, mein Mann ist aufgefallen in letzter Zeit.
Er sagte, dass ich so blaue Lippen habe. Häufig. So blaue Lippen.
Mir ist das gar nicht aufgefallen.
Blaue Lippen habe. Okay.
Ist Ihnen zu Ihrem Mann noch etwas eingefallen?
Nein, sonst nicht. Sonst nicht.
Ich habe so das Gefühl, dass ich so ein bisschen im rechten Bauch, so unter den Rippen, dass das da irgendwie so eng ist, dass es manchmal so drückt auf der rechten Seite an den Rippen.
Auch seit vier Wochen?
Ja, so nicht ganz, aber so in den letzten Tagen.
Ist Ihnen eingefallen, dass Ihre Beine geschwollen sind?
Ja, das stimmt. Besonders abends sind sie ziemlich angeschwollen.
Und morgens sind sie wieder etwas dünner, aber immer noch dick, immer noch geschwollen.
Haben Sie auch volle Gefühle, also ist Ihnen eingefallen, dass Sie schneller satt sind als sonst?
Nein, nicht unbedingt.
Und ist Ihr Bauch auch dicker geworden?
Ja, so ein bisschen vielleicht, aber wie gesagt, auf der rechten Seite oben am Bauch, da denke ich, ach, das ist manchmal so ein Druck.
So ein Druck, ja.
Das kann eine Lebervergrößerung sein. Und mit dem Lebervergrößerung können wir auch die Schwellungen an den Beinen erklären.
Okay.
Ja. Also gibt es noch etwas, die Sie hinzufügen möchten?
Nein, mir fällt im Augenblick nichts weiter ein.
Okay, also das waren die Fragen, die ich vorstellen möchte.
Ja.
Gut, dann danke. Dann haben Sie jetzt ja einige Minuten Zeit, sich vorzubereiten. Denken Sie an die Fachsprachebegriffe.
Und die Kolleginnen und Kollegen, die heute Abend zugeschaltet sind, haben vielleicht noch ein oder zwei ergänzende Fragen, die man vielleicht noch stellen könnte diesbezüglich.
Kann ich Sie eine Frage stellen?
Bitte.
Wo genau ist die Schwellung, bis Knöchel oder bis Knie?
Also im Bereich des Knöchels und so bis zur Mitte des Unterschenkels ungefähr.
Vorrückgängig bitte. Vorrückgängig bitte.
Ja, da sind Sie auf beiden Seiten.
Beide Seiten vorrückgängig. Danke.
Darf ich fragen?
Bitte.
Ja, Sie haben Luftnot. Haben Sie auch Husten?
Was habe ich noch?
Haben Sie auch Husten?
Ja, Husten habe ich auch. Das hatte die Kollegin schon gefragt.
Ja, ich habe Hustenreiz und manchmal auch etwas auswurf. Schleim ich, weise ich einen Auswurf. Ja, Hustenreiz habe ich auch.
Spüren Sie Brustschmerzen oder einige Gefühle beim Husten oder ein Atmen?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Wie viele Kissen legen Sie unter dem Rücken?
Ja, das muss ich jetzt mehr machen. Ich habe sonst immer mit einem Kissen geschlafen.
Aber so in den letzten Tagen und Wochen habe ich dann schon auch ein zweites Kissen genommen, damit mein Oberkörper etwas höher ist.
Okay.
Hab ich?
Ja.
Würde bei Ihnen Corona-Angiografie durchgeführt?
Was ist Corona-Angiografie?
Zum Beispiel ein Eingriff für Ihr Herzgefäß.
Ach so, Herzkatheter. Nein, bis jetzt noch nicht. Ich hatte ja bisher nur den hohen Blutdruck und den Zucker.
Da habe ich bisher gar keine Probleme gehabt.
Danke schön.
Essen Sie sehr salzig?
Nein, nein. Wir essen nicht sehr salzig. Wir haben auch gar keinen Salzstreuer am Tisch. Wir essen glaube ich wenig Salz.
Manchmal, wenn wir irgendwo anders sind, in einem Restaurant, kommt mir das manchmal sehr salzig vor, das Essen. Das mag ich nicht.
Gehen Sie die Wasserlassen meist am Abend, in der Nacht oder tagsüber?
Tagsüber muss ich auch etwas Wasser lassen. Auch von dieser Tablette, dieses Furusemit, da muss ich auch stark Wasser lassen.
Aber ich muss eben auch viel in der Nacht Wasser lassen, drei bis fünfmal.
Mehr als in der Nacht, ja?
Ja, ja, aber tagsüber auch. Aber nachts ist es besonders auffällig, dass sich das geändert hat. Es ist mehr geworden.
Mehr geworden. Danke schön.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Nein, mein Stuhlgang ist in Ordnung. Ich hatte jetzt gerade vor einem Jahr eine Vorsorge-Darmspiegelung, die war in Ordnung. Aber Stuhlgang habe ich kein Problem.
Linder die Schwellung, wenn Sie beim Hopplageren?
Das habe ich so noch nicht ausprobiert. Kann ich nicht sagen.
Okay.
Besuchen Sie Ihren Hausarzt regelmäßig?
Ja, zur Hausärztin gehe ich mindestens einmal im Jahr wegen der Impfungen im Herbst, aber auch so im Frühjahr.
Bald im Mai ist jetzt wieder dran, dass der Zucker überprüft wird. Da wird das Blut gemessen und dieser Zucker Langzeitwert gemessen.
Und dann muss ich auch zum Augenarzt, dass der meine Augen untersucht. Ja, das mache ich schon.
Ich messe auch ziemlich regelmäßig meinen Blutdruck. Der war eigentlich in letzter Zeit normal, aber der Puls war etwas höher. Der Herzschlag.
Ja, wollen Sie mal die Vorstellung machen?
Ja, okay. Hallo Herr Dr. Oberarzt. Ich habe eine neue Patiente aufgenommen und ich würde Sie gerne vorstellen, falls Sie Zeit haben.
Ja, habe ich.
Also die 63-jährige Frau Petra Sommerfeld ist 1,68 Meter hoch und wiegt 80 Kilogramm.
Sagen Sie ruhig 1,68 Meter groß. Groß, nicht hoch. Groß.
Okay, ich habe hoch gesagt. Okay, 1,68 Meter groß und wiegt 80 Kilogramm.
Frau Sommerfeld hat sich seit vier Wochen bestehende, prognodierte Dispnay vorgestellt.
Sie habe berichtet, dass sie manchmal, dass die Dispnay manchmal mit schleimiger Weiß, das zu den Dispnay auch manchmal schleimiger weißer Auswurf begleitet.
Nein, das nicht. Sie hat sich wegen Dispnay vorgestellt und sie hat auch gesagt, dass sie auch Tussis habe und die Tussis manchmal mit schleimiger Weiß Auswurf begleitet.
Die Atemnot vor vier Wochen leidet sie unter, ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, ausdrücken, ich kann nicht ausdrücken.
Also vorher waren die Dispnay belastet abhängig, aber seit zwei Tagen leidet sie unter Dispnay auch in Ruhe.
Man kann sagen Ruhedispnay oder Orthopnay? Ja, Ruhedispnay und auch Orthopnay hat sie auch.
Also die Symptomatik begann vor vier Wochen mit einer Belastungsdispnay?
Ja, hat sich im Laufe der Zeit verschlechtert und jetzt leidet sie unter Dispnay auch in Ruhe.
Okay, gut. Sie habe auch berichtet, dass sie in letzter Zeit ihre Puls sich erhöht habe und bei Frau Sommerfeld sei vor sieben Wochen Corona diagnostiziert.
Die Frage nach Halsschmerzen, Fieber, Nachschweiß, Stülpfrohs, Schluckbeschwerden, Brustschmerzen wurde verneint.
Aber Frau Sommerfeld habe in den letzten vier Wochen 5 kg zugenommen und sie leidet auch unter Insomni wegen Niktorie.
Wie oft ungefähr ist die Niktorie? Also 3-5 Mal.
Okay. Also vorher war es einmal, aber jetzt 3-5 Mal.
Außerdem hat Frau Sommerfeld berichtet, dass sie unter ihren Rippen, am rechten Seite unter ihren Rippen, eine Druckfühle und ihre Beine geschwollen seien.
Frau Sommerfeld berichtet über beidseitige Unterschenkel- und Knöchel-Oedäme und über ein unklares Druckgefühl im rechten Oberbauch.
Unklares Druckgefühl. Wir haben ja noch keine Diagnose.
Ja, das ist jetzt unklar.
Ja, bis jetzt unklar. Sie wissen wahrscheinlich, was es ist. Das haben Sie schon gesagt eben. Aber Frau Sommerfeld berichtet darüber.
Ja, das erzählen Sie jetzt. Also ich habe jetzt Folgendes verstanden.
Es handelt sich um eine 63-jährige Patientin, die 1,68 m groß ist und zurzeit 80 kg wiegt.
Frau Sommerfeld klagt seit ungefähr 4 Wochen über eine Belastungsdyspnoe und in den letzten Tagen über eine Ruhe bzw. Orthopnoe.
Sie berichtet über Husten mit etwas Auswurf oder Tussis mit etwas Auswurf, weißlich schleimig.
Und sie berichtet über Unterschenkel- und Knöchel-Oedäme beidseits sowie ein unklares Druckgefühl im rechten Oberbauch.
Und über eine 3- bis 5-malige Nykturie. Das ist neu. Das hat sich in den letzten 4 Wochen entwickelt.
Diese Nykturie?
Nykturie ist nicht neu, aber hat sich in den letzten 4 Wochen verstärkt.
Verstärkt, ok.
Aber ist nicht neu.
Gut, Frau Sommerfeld hatte eine Corona-Infektion vor ungefähr 7 Wochen.
Ja, eine Corona-Infektion wurde bei ihr diagnosiert.
Hat Frau Sommerfeld chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, sie leidet an arteriöler Hypotonie seit 8 Jahren.
Und sie nimmt dagegen kein Satan 8 mg. Einmal morgens und einmal abends.
Und sie nimmt auch bis zu Prolol 5 mg. Einmal morgens und eine halbe Tablette abends ein.
Und sie nimmt auch vor SEMIT 40 mg. Einmal morgens dagegen ein.
Ok.
Und außerdem leidet Frau Sommerfeld auch an Diabetes Melitus seit 2 Jahren.
Und dagegen nimmt sie mit Formin 850 mg. Einmal morgens und eine halbe abends.
Also ist es wahrscheinlich ein Diabetes Melitus Typ 2?
Ja, ja.
Gut, gibt es Voroperationen?
Bei Frau Sommerfeld wurde in ihrem Kindheit eine Nabelbruchoperation, ein Translektomien durchgeführt.
Ja, das Wort Nabelbruch. Können Sie da den Fachbegriff sagen?
Das fällt mir jetzt nicht ein.
Umbilical Hernia. Umbilicus ist der Nabel.
Und eine Umbilical Hernia. Und die Operation ist eine Herniotomie.
Ist eine Umbilical Herniotomie durchgeführt.
Sagen Sie ruhig, es wurde bei der Patientin im Kindesalter eine Herniotomie durchgeführt wegen Umbilical Hernia.
Weil man kann auch eine Herniotomie bei Inguinal Hernia durchführen.
Die Herniotomie ist nur die Bruchoperation. Leistenbruch oder ein Nabelbruch.
Sagen Sie ruhig, die Diagnose ist Umbilical Hernia und die Therapie ist die Herniotomie.
Gut, verstanden.
Und vor zwölf Jahren wurde bei Frau Sommerfeld wegen Cholidithiasis eine Cholizistektomie durchgeführt.
Ja, ok, gut.
Ja, und außer den genannten Medikamenten nimmt sie keine anderen Medikamente ein.
Sie leider auch bei Frau Sommerfeld ist auch nicht allergienbekannt.
Sie ist eine Nichtraucherin und sie trinkt sehr selten ein Glas Wein und hat auch keine Kontakt mit Drogen.
Sie ist vollständig geimpft und die Heiseeinnahmenese ist auch unauffällig.
Ihr Vater leider ist an Herzinsuffizienz gestorben.
Wie alt war der Vater da?
Sie hat 78 Jahre alt gesagt.
Ja, oder 76, 78. Ja, das stimmt.
Und ihre Mutter leider an Asthma.
Und die Mutter hat noch eine Diagnose. Kniegelenkathrose.
Ja, das habe ich vergessen zu notizen.
Kniegelenkathrose, können Sie da den Fachbegriff sagen?
Gonathrose. Genau.
Gut. Ja.
Gibt es Geschwister?
Ja, er habe einen Bruder und seine Bruder leider auch an alterlich Petronier und Hypercholesterinämie.
Er sei verheiratet und lebe mit ... Sie, Sie, Sie.
Ja, sie habe einen Bruder, er leidet an alterlich Petronier.
Sie sei verheiratet und lebe mit ihrem Mann zusammen. Sie hat zwei Kinder, die gesund seien.
Ist sie noch berufstätig?
Danach habe ich vergessen.
Das haben Sie vergessen zu fragen. Sie ist Sekretärin bei einem Rechtsanwalt.
Das ist der Beruf der Patientin. Das ist jetzt nicht ganz so entscheidend.
Manche Berufe sind vielleicht für bestimmte Erkrankungen schon wichtig.
Aber in diesem Falle ist es jetzt nicht so wichtig. Sie hat eine Arbeit im Büro.
Ja, sie ist Büroarbeiterin.
Gut. Ja. Was ist denn Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Also die Angaben deuten am ehesten auf eine Lebererkrankung hin.
Ja, Lebererkrankung, also das kann ein Lebezirrus sein.
Es kann auch eine Hepatitis sein.
Was käme sonst noch infrage? Denken Sie an die Dispnoe, an die Belastungsdispnoe?
Nach oben. Ja, das kann auch eine Herzinsuffizienz sein.
Ja.
Okay. Also ich würde auch sagen, wahrscheinlich hat die Patientin eine Myokatinsuffizienz, eine Herzinsuffizienz, die jetzt dekompensiert.
Sie hat jetzt begann mit Belastungsdispnoe und jetzt hat sie eine Orthopnoe und sie hat zunehmende Gewichtseinlagerung, Wassereinlagerung in dem Komplor.
Und hat Ödeme und hat wahrscheinlich ist das eine Hepatomegalie, ein Staubungsleber.
Das hatten Sie ganz zu Anfang mal gesagt bei der Patientin.
Ich glaube, Sie haben eine Staubungsleber, haben Sie gesagt.
Das war ja schon durchaus ganz richtig.
Eventuell kann diese Herzinsuffizienz mit der zurückliegenden Corona-Infektion zu tun haben.
Das kann ja durchaus sein.
Das wurde ja beobachtet nach Corona.
Nicht nur Myokaditis, sondern auch Herzinsuffizienzen.
Aber gut, die Patientin ist 63 Jahre alt.
Da kann man auch mal, gerade wenn man einen Hypertonus hat, auch durchaus mal eine Herzinsuffizienz bekommen.
Und Corona hat das vielleicht noch beschleunigt.
Mit der Diagnose Leberzirrhose, ja gut.
Wir haben bisher noch nichts gehört, dass die Patientin vielleicht mal eine Hepatitis gehabt hat.
Oder dass sie eine Alkoholanamnese hat.
Oder was hinweist vielleicht auf einen erhöhten Alkoholkonsum.
Das ist bisher nicht bekannt, aber das kann durchaus sein.
Wir wissen es nicht genau.
Differentialdiagnostisch kommt das sicherlich in Betracht.
Es wurde da geschrieben Lungenödem.
Lungenödem wäre ja mehr.
Auch dann eine Linkserzinsuffizienz.
Ja, kann auch mit einer Rolle spielen.
Ich würde aber jetzt eher sagen, dass sie eine Rechtsherzinsuffizienz hat, die Patientin.
Vielleicht sogar eine globale Insuffizienz.
Aber wahrscheinlich rechtsführend.
Sprecht so die Staung dafür.
Die Unterschenkelödem, die Beinödeme, die Hepatomegalie.
Wahrscheinlich ist es eine Hepatomegalie.
Wahrscheinlich hat die Patientin vielleicht auch Pleurergüsse.
Oder ein Pleurerguss, das wissen wir noch nicht.
Sie untersuchen sie ja noch.
Und sie machen dann noch die bildgebenden Verfahren, denke ich.
Das kommt ja alles.
Erstmal vielen Dank.
Ich denke, insgesamt haben Sie das sehr gut gemacht.
Ich habe Sie gut verstanden.
Sie haben sich gut ausgedrückt, einen guten Satzbau.
Bei der Frage mit den Symptomen, da würde ich immer noch mal ganz kurz gezielt sagen.
Sie hat angegeben seit vier Wochen,
Sie hat eine hohe Nervatnö, jetzt verschlimmert Richtung Ruhe.
Sie hat Gewichtseinlagerung.
Sie hat die Nukturie.
Die Frequenz hat sich erhöht von normal einmal auf drei- bis fünfmal.
Das ist schon mal eine wichtige anamnestische Angabe.
Dann war die Frage, mit wie viel Kissen kann die Patientin liegen?
Sie muss in letzter Zeit ihr Oberkörper erhöht hinlegen.
Sonst kriegt sie gar keine Luft.
Das ist typisch.
Das spricht eher für eine Herzinsuffizienz als für eine reine Leberproblematik.
Aszitis, glaube ich nicht, dass die Patientin Aszitis hat.
Sie hat ja gesagt, sie hat nur ein Druckgefühl hier rechts oben im Oberbauch.
Das kann ich auch nicht fragen.
Nein, haben Sie auch nicht gefragt.
Aber insgesamt gesehen, denke ich, haben Sie das sehr gut gemacht.
Das ist richtig.
Da können Sie sich auch gut ausdrücken.
Meine Frage ist, wann machen Sie Prüfung?
Am 30. März.
Ja, ist doch alles gut vorbereitet.
Wo machen Sie die Prüfung?
In Karlsruhe.
Okay, gut.
Also aus meiner Sicht...
Also läuft besser.
Aber diesmal habe ich nicht geschafft.
Ja, ja.
Insgesamt haben Sie das gut geschafft.
Die Chatbemerkung war, einmal in der Nacht Wasser lassen,
gilt noch nicht definitionsgemäß als Nukturie.
Das glaube ich auch, das stimmt.
Man sagt einmal nächtliches Wasser lassen,
aber der Begriff ist schon mal wichtig, Nukturie.
Ich möchte sagen, die Patientin hat gesagt,
mein Mann hat beobachtet, ich habe so blaue Lippen.
Kennen Sie da den Begriff für blaue Lippen?
Nein.
Man sagt Lippenzyanose.
Zyanose heißt Zyanose.
Zyanose ist die Blau-Verfärbung.
Es gibt eine Lippenzyanose und es gibt auch eine Fingerzyanose.
Der Peripherie.
Das ist ein Zeichen einer Problematik mit dem Herzen.
Eine Lippenzyanose.
Fällt den Patienten oft selbst nicht auf den Angehörigen.
Ja.
Gut.
Aber ich habe ein gutes Gefühl für Ihre Prüfung in Karlsruhe.